What I do is is I hop on panels. I hop
on Israel panels. I hop on Muslim
panels. I hop on Jehovah's Witness
panels. And I cause each and every one
of you cult groups to panic.
>> Yeah, I for sure believe that salvation
is definitely not for not only for the
Israelites. So, um I think that we can
we can get into that real quick. Um I
got a verse that I think is pretty
clear. There's a there's quite a few,
but uh one verse that I I think it's
pretty clear is in Isaiah 49. Um it
talks about the salvation to uh that God
is going to bring. So, if we can go to
that real quick.
>> When you go to Isaiah, right, read verse
23 and explain that, too.
>> Okay. All right. So Isaiah 49 uh I'll
start at verse 5. And now the Lord says
he who formed me from the womb to be his
servant to bring Jacob back to him and
that Israel might be gathered to him.
For I am honored in the eyes of Yahweh
and my God has become my strength. He
says it is too light a thing that you
should be my servant to raise up the
tribes of Jacob. Now, before I continue
reading, who would you guys say are the
tribes of Jacob?
>> Uh, the tribes of Jacob, that would be
the Israelites, of course, and the
preserved Israel, that would be a
specific portion of the Israelites. And
then when it says the lights of the
light to the Gentiles is referring to
the scattered Israelites, which um, of
course, some of them might be of the
preserve of Israel as well. And of
course, they would also be part of the
12 tribes of Jacob.
>> Okay. So, it seems like um because
that'll be a little bit redundant. It
says because it makes distinctions here.
>> The Bible say the Bible is very
redundant.
>> I I disagree. It says to raise up the
tribes of Jacob. The tw the tribes would
be the 12 tribes of Israel. Is that
correct?
>> The tribes of Jacob. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that's so the 12 tribes are
covered. And he says, "And to bring back
the preserved of Israel." Who are the
preserved of Israel that are not that he
needs to bring back?
>> Again, being redundant, they're still
part of the 12 tribes of Jacob.
>> No worries. But who are the ones who are
who need to be brought back?
>> Means the remnant. The remnant, brother.
>> Right. So, who are the That's the
remnant that he's talking about. Okay.
>> The remnant is the very elect of the
Israelites. Out of all 12 tribes, is
going to be one-third as a remnant, as
it says in Zechariah.
>> Yeah. But where are they?
>> Yeah. What what I would say I I wouldn't
say u I wouldn't put a number on that
cuz in in specific um in specific
scriptures it does say the remnant would
be I I think it said 5,000 or something
like that that had not bowed
>> sorry that's preached in the last days
or prophets in the last day. He has
7,000 that won't bow to the knee bow
their knees to be ba but
every
>> Yeah. So in in every in in every
captivity he had a preserve that didn't
uh serve the other gods
>> right
>> okay so the preserved of Israel are the
remnant correct that he needs to bring
back would you say that these remnant
are scattered
>> yes 400
>> I don't I I don't I don't know in this
particular context here if they are the
ones that are scattered
>> well it says they need to be brought
back.
>> Say that again.
>> It says they need to be brought back.
Where are they being brought back to?
>> They would be brought back to the to the
land at some point. Right.
>> Right. So, they're scattered.
>> Okay.
>> Have to be brought back to the knowledge
of God and who we are.
>> Yeah. But also also the 12 tribes of
Jacob are scattered as well. Right.
>> Uh not except not not not all of them
though because you have some that are
that were still in the land, right? But
And that that was up up until 70 AD.
>> All right. So in 70 AD, you're saying
that every Israelite was scattered from
from Israel from Jerusalem.
>> Well, not every single one. Like they
might have been a couple. You know what
I'm saying? Maybe a couple a couple
dozen that might have survived and you
know slipped through the cracks, but the
majority were all um out of there. They
were out of Jerusalem. They were either
taken in captivity or migrated out of
there.
>> Yeah. So it says caught up in the
invasion of of of the Rome invading
Israel. We were scattered all the way
since going back into Assyrian
captivity, the Babylonian captivities,
the Greek captivities. We've been
constantly being scattered since the
world was created.
>> So it's not just Rome chasing us out of
uh Jerusalem that caused the diaspora,
>> right? So what we have here is we have
the 12 tribes of Jacob. We have the
remnant of Israel.
>> What happened here? Right. second
coming.
>> So this means so guys so the the tribes
of Jacob
>> and the preserves of and the preserved
of Israel
>> that's all of Israel that's accounted
for right the scattered the
non-scattered the ones that's all all
about this is an entire Israel is
accounted for in that passage right
>> yes I don't want you to be offended but
I'm ask you this but when you see a
colon when you reading English and you
see a colon what does a colon mean
everything after the colon means what
>> it's another thought that's about to be
added.
>> No, everything after the colon describes
what was written before the colon. Look
that up.
>> It's another thought that's about to be
added to what's being said.
>> You're making grammatical errors,
brother. That's all I'm telling you.
>> I disagree. What is what is he speaking
to before the colon? That's a basic law
in English. Go around that.
>> Yeah. before before the colon, the
subject is the person, the servant
that's going to be raising up the tribes
of Jacob and bringing back the berser of
Israel. So after the colon, he then
continues to address him and says, "I
will make you as a light to the
nations."
>> Okay. So, uh, so who would the Gentiles
be right here? If before the colon is
Israel, who would the Gentiles be after
the colon?
>> Well, that's that's the point. So, if
you have if you have respect,
>> brother, can I can I respond to you? Cuz
you ask me a question and you're not
letting me actually answer you.
>> I want you to teach correctly. That's
all I'm saying.
>> That's fine. If if you disagree with me,
that's fine. But like, you got to at
least let me You got You have to at
least allow me to engage with you,
brother. Brother, you have to you have
to allow me to engage with you agenda.
>> For you to cut me off is showing that
either you're afraid of what I have to
say or or something's going on. I don't
know what it is, but you got to you
let him Yeah. Let him finish his ass.
>> He's making a grammatical error. Go
ahead, brother. You can you can say that
all you want without any proof. That's
fine. So So we all agree that to raise
up and what comes before
>> Hey, what's up with this brother, man?
What's up with this brother?
>> See, I'm not a fan of looking for fans.
I'm not.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Let's just try Let's
just try to not speak over each other.
>> This is crazy.
>> Nah, nah. We We ain't talking about
fans. You know what I'm saying?
>> We We're gonna try to just do everything
in decency and in order. We're not gonna
try to overt talk each other. So he he
had a thought and his his his Okay, let
me let me um try to say what your
>> um he's still on Isaiah 49, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we're on Isaiah 49. So now
when you're saying when you're saying
that Jacob, right, the 12 tribes of
Jacob,
>> brother, I was cut off from what I was
saying.
>> That's what I'm hear.
>> Yeah, I can hear you. I'm saying I was
cut I was I was making my point and the
brother just kept cutting me off and I
haven't been able to make my point yet.
>> All right. All right. So, just before
you make your point, right, I just want
to make sure that I'm clear, that I'm
clear on what you're trying to say. When
it says the 12 tribes of Jacob, you're
saying that that and they're preserved
of Israel, that that encompasses all of
the Israelites, including the ones that
are all scattered. And on the next
thought, that it's not going to be
including any Israelites.
>> Well, that's what I'm just asking right
now.
So,
>> okay. So, if you're just asking that,
then the answer is those Gentiles on the
next in the next uh right after that
colon.
>> Those Gentiles are the scattered
Israelites.
>> But the scattered Israelites were
already mentioned here as the tribes of
Jacob.
>> Can I just ask him one question?
>> So, how are they the Well, just really
quick, guys, cuz you guys got You have
to let me know.
>> It's just one question and then I'm
going to shut up.
>> I know.
Notice how notice how everybody has been
saying something
>> and not allowing just just really quick,
brother, cuz this is not what's going to
happen.
>> Who's the
>> I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to
say what I'm going to say.
>> This is like this is getting ridiculous.
>> Let him finish cuz when he get to seven,
he'll see go back to
let him finish. I got to let him finish
so he can answer his question. You know
what I'm saying? We don't want him to
say that
>> thing like he was doing on Beard Live.
>> I appreciate it. I wasn't on Bear's live
yesterday.
>> No. Um, the coding Big Bear was doing
like a live we don't need time. All All
we need is self-control, fellas. If we
have I'm talking to the hoes, bro.
>> If we have if we have and I'm talking to
you. If we have if we have self-control.
If we have self-control and we commune
like like grown men. We don't need
timers. We could talk to each other.
>> It could get annoying when you're
hearing the same lies over and over. So,
I
>> I I agree. But have self-control.
Control yourself. That's all.
That's pretty hypocritical due to the
fact I see you interrupt Muslims over
and over again on your panel.
>> I don't.
>> Yeah. Listen. Wait. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Is he serious?
>> I'm dead serious.
>> I hate hypocritical Christians. I hate
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> I love you, bro.
>> Hold on. Everybody chill out. Chill out.
Chill out.
>> Wait. Wait. Chill out. We're not We're
not going to have a conversation. We're
not going to get angry at each other.
We're not going to do that. I just want
to have a discussion with God logic. So
if we could do if we could do that and
decency and in order maybe everybody can
ask a question that that's cool if he's
cool with it. But everybody got to chill
out. You know what I'm saying? Because I
ain't trying to hear that oh we jumped
them and that we ain't give him a chance
to talk. I don't want to hear that later
on.
>> Yeah. So
it says it is too light a thing that you
should be my servant to raise up the
tribes of Jacob. You guys already said
that. That's the 12 tribes. and bring
back the pres and and you said that
these 12 tribes are scattered already
and to bring back the preserved of
Israel, the scattered remnant. So the
scattered Israelites are already
mentioned. Can we agree?
>> No. So what you're talking about when
Hold on, hold on a second. So when it
says the preserved Israel,
man,
>> it's talking about a specific a specific
portion of the scattered Israelites.
It's not talking about all the scattered
Israelites here.
>> Uh when it mentions the 12 tribes of
Israel, are the 12 tribes scattered?
>> I'mma give you an example. I'mma give
you an example so that you can
understand the distinction between them.
Right? So now there are some scattered
Israelites that understood they were
Israelites. But then there's a whole lot
of them that don't even remember that
they that they were Israelites or that
didn't keep the law. They weren't
circumcising their children. You know
what I'm saying? They were they were
eating swine's flesh and so on and so
forth. I'mma read a scripture to show
you that. Right.
>> So this this is
>> that has nothing to do with them being
scattered, brother.
>> But um it does. Yes, it does. Logic. It
does.
>> I just want to know if these tribes
>> I just want to know if these tribes are
scattered.
>> I don't understand why he haven't read
his Bible.
>> Margo.
>> Dang. So many emotions.
Israelites.
You see what I'm saying? I'm trying to
have a conversation with him. Margo,
chill out. I want to read the scripture
so that we can get the conversation
going, then I can move on to the next
person. But y gotta chill.
>> They're so emotional, host, what's going
on with them?
>> No, no, no. Don't Don't do that.
>> I'm not emotional. You don't read your
Bible.
>> Don't start trying to antagonize him.
Don't do that.
>> What you mean, bro?
>> No. No. Don't Don't do it.
>> Decoding. Ask him who are the
Israelites.
>> Yeah. Yeah. He not he not going to be
able to answer.
>> That's the thing. Hold. You know, you
know you know I'm ask him that. For
anybody to understand a book, you got to
know who the people of the book is, man.
>> You know, and you know why he can't
answer that? Because at the same time,
he knows,
bro.
>> He know if he say that it's not them
over there. If it's not them over there,
then he going to have a target on his
back. He cannot say that. You know what
I'm saying?
>> But he know it ain't them over there.
>> But how can you understand a book if you
don't know the book?
>> Let me let me read this scripture.
Right. Let the host
>> just to show you just to show you just
to show you a scripture, right? Talking
about the the Israelites that were out
there and they were not keeping the law
and all that. I'm going read first
Mcabes chapter 1 verse 41. It says,
"Moreover, King Aielkus wrote to his
whole kingdom that all should be one
people." So this is um the king in
Greeks and he's saying that all the
people under his kingdom, all the
different nations under his kingdom,
they are to be one people with the
Greeks, right? And everyone should leave
his laws, they are to stop following
their own laws and they are to keep the
laws of the Greeks. So all the heathen
agreed according to the commandment of
the king. All these other nations, they
all agreed, all the nations that were
under the the Greek Empire, they all
agreed to keep the laws and to be one
people with the Greeks. Yay. Many also
of the Israelites consented to his
religion and sacrificed unto idols and
profaneed the Sabbath. So also many of
the Israelites did the same where they
left their own laws. They stopped
keeping their own customs and they
followed after the customs of the Greeks
beca becoming one people with the
Greeks. For the king had sent letters by
messengers onto Jerusalem and the cities
of Judah, that they should follow the
strange laws of the land, and forbid
burnt offerings and sacrifice and drink
offerings in the temple, that they
should profane the Sabbaths and festival
days, and pollute the sanctuary and holy
people, set up altars and groves and
chapels of idols, and sacrifice swines,
flesh, and unclean beasts. They were
also eating pigs and cramp, crab,
lobster, all that stuff. Y Christians
love that stuff. So this is what they
were doing, right? They were keeping the
customs of the Greeks. They no longer
followed their own laws. They were
eating swine's flesh. They were
sacrificing to the Greek idols and so on
and so forth, right? Becoming one people
with the Greeks.
>> Verse 48.
>> Read me. You said you gonna me. I'mma
read up. I'mma read up to I'mma read up
to verse 52. That's it.
>> Dang.
>> So this verse 48,
>> this verse 48. It ain't that long. It
ain't that long. that they als that they
should also leave their children
uncircumcised. Which means these
Israelites were not circumcising their
children and make their souls abominable
with all manner of uncleanliness and
profanation to the end that they might
forget the law. After a few generations,
they started to forget their law and
change their ordinance. They changed it
to what? To the Greek ordinance. Because
now they're one people with the Greek.
And whosoever would not do according to
the commandment of the king, he said, he
should die. So I got one question for
you. If these Israelites could no longer
call themselves Jews, cuz if they do,
they'd be unal alive. They can't
circumcise their children because if
they do, them children get unal alive.
If they can't keep um their own laws,
their own ordinances, and they now
become one people with the Greeks
speaking their language and going and
following their customs, what are they
calling themselves? Uh, they're still
Israelites.
What would
>> you need to read the book of Fasians?
They're still they're still Israelites
and they still call themselves
Israelites as you see when they when
Jesus comes. And this is this is
my brother. Please allow please allow me
to speak. Please allow me to speak.
That's fine. Can I speak? Are you going
to speak?
>> Notice how I said two words, Nico. I
said two words and your people have no
self-control. Hold on. Not check it.
Logic. Logic.
>> No, brother. Cuz I got I got I have to
be able to get off my my my like I I
have to be able to speak here. If you
guys are going to cut me off at every
turn, we can't have a conversation.
Like, what is this? Let me finish my
point.
>> But but but wait, but wait. Hold on. I'm
wait.
I'm going let you speak. And if you want
the same thing, it's cool.
>> No, I'm gonna let you speak and and if
you want to say the repeat the same
thing, it's cool. But that is a lot
because no worries if you think it's a
Hold on. Dakota could stop. You're
you're stopping me to address something
I didn't even get to continue saying.
>> Let you address it. I'm gonna let you
address it. But I You said that last
time. You said I was going to be able to
speak. You said you're going to read
these verses. You're going to let me
speak. I am going to Then you didn't
even let me make the point that I was
making before. You switched the
question. Now I'm responding to what you
brought up and now you're not letting me
say that nothing now. Right now I don't
understand what's happening. Do you guys
want a conversation or not? You know
what? Go ahead. I'm gonna let you say
what you got to say. Try not to be too
longwinded and then I'mma respond.
>> Try not to be too longwinded after you
just read an entire passage that had
nothing to do with what I was saying
before.
>> If you don't if you going to read some
verses, go ahead. You can read some
verses. I'm not going to time you on
some verses, but if you going to go on
this long tangent and you're not
actually reading, that's a different
story. That's all I'm talking about. But
go ahead.
>> All right. So,
tell your clown stop typing stuff in the
chat. It sounds stupid.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The Christians are calling
you out for your Christian clowns to
stop typing.
>> The Christians are calling you out cuz
you're a clown. They're calling you out.
He's not
>> Look at these Israelites, y'all. These
tough Israelites.
>> Look at these tough Israelites. No
self-control.
Look at these tough Israelites.
>> No fruit of the spirit.
>> Look at these amazing Israelites. These
these people of God. Look at them. Stop.
Marvel. Look at him.
>> Margo, Judah, everybody just mute up
your mic. Let him say his peace so he
can stop talking AND [__]
>> BUT HE HASN'T SAID ANYTHING.
>> Too emotional.
>> Margo. Margo.
>> She said I hasn't said I haven't said
anything.
>> Margo, stop. Margo, stop.
>> They They cut me off at every turn and
then say I haven't said anything.
>> I'm trying to have these hypocr. I'm
trying to have the conversation with
Logic. If if you can't mute your mic,
just drop down and then y'all can come
up after.
>> Yeah, they can't handle this Dakota.
They can't.
>> Go ahead, Logic. chaggonize
nobody on the panel either.
>> I'm not trying to. I'm just talking to
you, man. They're not ready. They're not
ready for this, honestly.
>> But, okay. So, like I was saying, they
still refer to themselves as Israelites
because as you see, even when Jesus was
dealing with the Jews, they literally
said, "We are Jews and Abraham is our
father." That's what they were claiming.
They were claiming, "We are the Jews. We
are the Israelites. Abraham is our
father." They're still referring to
themselves as Israelites even under
Roman rule. So again, they are still
Israelites. Now, going back to what I
was what I was asking you. Notice this
is this has nothing to do with what
they're calling themselves. We're
talking about what God is saying here.
God is speaking in Isaiah 49:6.
And he is the one who identified them as
Israelites, as the 12 tribes of Jacob,
as the remnant of Israel, the preserved
of Israel. This is what God identifies
them as. I don't care what they say. I'm
I'm only bringing what God says. And so
what God says is here it's too light a
thing that you should be my servant to
raise up the tribes of Jacob which you
all have already agreed that these are
the 12 tribes that are scattered. You
guys already said that. And to raise uh
bring back the preserved or the remnant
of Israel. You guys already agreed out
of your mouth. I have it recorded that
you guys said that these are scattered
remnant Israelites. So again, the
scattered Israelites are already
accounted for. Can we agree that
mentioned in verse 6 before we get to
the nations parts?
>> We already said no.
>> So I I already answered that. And that's
not all the scattered Israelites cuz
again, although you mentioned those that
said Abraham is our father, those Jews,
those are talking about Jews that knew
who they were. I already mentioned that
some of them knew who they were and
others did not. Why? And I read the
scripture. I read these all these verses
from verse 41 to verse 52 showing you
how they became one people with the
Greeks. They were not allowed under the
threat of the short. They were not
allowed to call themselves Jews. They
were not allowed to keep their own laws.
And it says even that they might forget
the law and change all the order.
>> Were they still Israelites?
>> Hold on. These are Israelites. Yes,
these are Israelites.
>> Scattered Israelites. Hold on, hold on.
And it says that they should also leave
their they also should leave their
children uncircumcised. Which means
these were uncircumcised Israelites.
>> All of this is irrelevant. Are they
Israelites?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Now the Jews
that you're referring to, those were
circumcised Jews.
>> Where does it say?
>> You You know why? You know why? Cuz they
were the ones trying to enforce
circumcision to the other to the other.
in verse six. Does it does it make a
distinction between circumcised Jews and
nonc I'm talking about I'm talking about
the ones you mentioned you said the ones
that said Abraham is our father that's
talking about those Jews that were in um
that knew that they were Jews. So
there's a distinction between those that
knew they were Jews and were keeping the
customs of
>> I I hear what you're saying. Where in
Isaiah 49:6 does it make that
distinction?
>> Hold on. Hold on. It's showing you right
there when it says when it says the
preserved of Israel and then it says the
the light to the Gentiles, right? Those
Gentiles is still talking about
Israelites that are scattered.
>> See, now hold on. Wait, wait, wait.
Stop. You see how you keep interrupting
me, right?
>> Well, I'm not. I thought we were having
a conversation.
>> Go ahead. Yeah. You You didn't like You
didn't like when I was interrupting you
and I stopped interrupting you, but then
you kept interrupting me the entire
time.
>> Somebody else
at you guys. Give me a minute. Yeah,
man.
>> Now, when it said when it's when it's
talking about those Gentiles there,
those Gentiles, it's talking about
Israelites that either they didn't know
they were Israelites or didn't really
care. Just like today, there's a lot of
Israelites that either don't know
they're Israelites or don't even care to
know if they're Israelites. That's today
as well. Just like it was back then.
Why? Because you have um centuries of
them living under the other nations,
calling themselves by the name of the
nations in which they dwelling. They're
not calling themselves Israelites
anymore. Why? Because the Jews don't
consider them Israelites. The Jews don't
consider them equal. The Jews are
looking down at them at that time. And
Christ when he came, what he did was he
was restoring them, bringing them back,
saying they are just like you. You're
not supposed to treat them any
different. That was the whole point.
>> You're being long-winded.
>> I'm done. Go ahead.
>> Okay,
>> Dakota, you got to read. Can you read?
>> My question is My question is very
simple, Dakota. I'm a I'm I'm going to
read. It says, "It is too light a thing
that you should be my servant to raise
up the tribes of Jacob and to bring back
the preserved of Israel.
>> I will also make you a light to the
Gentiles that my salvation might reach
the may reach the ends of the earth."
Here's my question. Very, very simple.
>> It's very, very simple. My question is
very, very simple, guys. Look how
nervous these people are. Look how y'all
are in panic mode, boy.
to the next verse.
>> Fidgety. My goodness.
>> Where in verse six, can you get your
people under control, Dakota? They're
not ready for this.
>> Go ahead. Just Just go ahead.
>> They're They're not emotionally or
spiritually stable enough for to have
this conversation with you.
>> They're not ready, Dakota. They're not
ready.
>> Dakota, do you mind do you mind removing
the babes?
>> Y'all got to let the brother listen,
brothers. Can you remove the babes from
the stage
>> in order for me to have the
conversation?
>> Can you remove the children, please?
>> Ends of the earth.
>> Can you remove the children?
>> Earth is flat.
>> Can you Can you remove the children?
Have him read verse seven and eight.
>> Can you remove the children from the
stage, Dakota?
>> I'm going to read seven and eight. He's
not going to just leave. I am going to
read seven and eight. But y if y'all
keep doing that, then he's going to
leave and say we ain't let him talk.
>> Let let him asking the brother
questions. She already because these
these clowns can't these clowns cannot
control themselves.
>> This is what I do. What I do is is I hop
on panels. I hop on Israel panels. I hop
on Muslim panels. I hop on Jehovah's
Witness panels and I cause each and
every one of you cults to panic.
>> He asks the same question.
>> Y'all are panics. Panic mode for you to
change your answer. That's what he does.
>> Panic mode.
>> I just need him to ask his question.
>> Panic mode for what though? Because
because I'm here destroying you and
exposing you. I'm exposing you. That's
why you're panicking.
>> Are you [__] or some [__] bro?
>> Uh-oh. Hey, he can't say that. Your life
is going to get you asking flag.
>> Look at
Hey, I'm going to let y'all know, man.
Thousands of people are going to see
this, man. They're going to be laughing
at you guys.
>> Yes. Yes. Expose yourself.
>> Who cares?
>> Keep exposing yourself.
>> Shut the stand down, boy.
>> Look at these Look at these Look at
these guys. Look at these demons. Just
let him say what he has to say. It's
easy to deal with the verse. Just let
him say it.
>> Amazing. It looks like we got Okay, all
the kids are leaving. Good.
>> All right.
Okay. Decoding in Isaiah 49:6
where in the verse hold a second before
before you ask your question, I am going
to read the next verse. So this is
verse.
>> This is getting absolutely ridiculous
that you tell me not to cut you off.
>> Stop.
>> Why can't you read the next verse after
I speak?
>> Why do you have to interrupt me to do
this?
>> Logic. Wait. Wait.
>> No. There's no waiting. You just speak
for a long time. You want you want to
wait till it's my turn to speak to then
read verse seven.
>> You got You have to wait. Yes, you have.
>> Yeah. No, this read the verses and then
I'm going to let you ask the questions.
So this is uh Isaiah 49. Read from verse
5 on down to 8. It says, "And now sayith
the Lord that formed me from the womb to
be
>> and they muted me, guys.
>> To bring
>> Yeah. Don't Don't mute him, guys. Don't
mute him. To bring
>> He just came up and interrupted you,
brother.
>> Yeah, he interrupted me like a
hypocrite.
>> Oh. Oh, now I'm a hypocrite. I get
interrupted. I get interrupted. I demand
the same respect I'm giving you guys.
And yet I'm the hypocrite.
>> I'm the hypocrite.
>> Stop. Logic. Stop. Cuz then I'mma have
to mute you. My mind.
>> You're the one cutting me off when it
was my floor to speak. Dude,
>> [__] got to stop.
>> Why do I have to stop when it's my floor
to speak?
>> I'm going to give you the floor. I'm
gonna give you the floor.
>> You just gave me the floor and
interrupting me.
>> No. Uhuh. Uhuh.
>> Taking the floor. I'm taking the floor
back cuz I a whole lot of people.
>> So, I'm going to give you the floor
back, but you got to let me read the
verses. So, this is Isaiah 49 and verse
5. It says,
>> "Oh, I thought you was going to read
verse seven."
>> I said verse 5, 6, 7, and 8. That's what
Hey, brother. Hey, brother. Listen.
Look, bro. What what you're
demonstrating right now, you're
demonstrating the cowardice of the
Israelites that's not allowing. When a
Christian comes When a Christian comes
and challenges you guys, you guys cannot
stand up to the challenge. You guys
cannot have a conversation or
discussion. You guys are pathetic.
You're a pathetic
cultist. Pathetic.
>> An excuse to run.
>> Oh yeah, it's an excuse to run when you
guys don't let me speak. I'm out of
here.
>> Excuse you. Take care of yourself, you
cowards. Take care.